it is yes no that's right that's right
so isn't it funny isn't it if if that's
exactly right if Zedd was your Universal
set then these two are not compliments
because they're both missing zero right
so zero would be yeah it's outside zero
always see you would be in this camp
obviously zero theorems always ruining
things but anyhow what would the next
step be we actually have a name for and
you know what the name is
we're numbers aren't whole what we call
it we call on rational numbers now then
you think oh I'll put an R no we're not
going to put that we'll save you
we're not even cor gonna call our f for
fractions because there are numbers that
are in this set I'm gonna tell you about
that isn't gonna affect it I'm gonna put
a queue like this
so we have extra lines so that you don't
think it's a number cute just like by
convention you know if you're in a
diagram right like this is here some
geometry right by convention just so
that we have a similar set of rules and
everything is not just random we usually
use capital letters for vertices and we
usually use lowercase letters for sides
and we usually use Greek letters for
angles right and that's just so usually
not all the time but usually in the same
way yeah okay we usually use them now to
choose the set of rational numbers does
anyone have any guesses as to why it's a
queue not that hard actually this one's
this one doesn't appeal to another
language like this one Q 4 Q 4 for now I
think this is about rational numbers
fractions kind of division equations
that's right so this is kind of a
reference search that's that operation
okay rational numbers okay now now we're
missing some numbers right I've got all
the whole numbers I've got some
negatives in here as well now I can have
1/2 1/3 1/4 and so on okay but there are
lots of numbers between missing
okay so I can say irrational numbers now
the thing is even the name itself
irrational numbers right it tells you
that this set here this set is defined
in terms of another step irrational
means not rational so the most common
sense way to write this would be to say
it's the complement of Q okay now
obviously you've got to be a little
careful don't you because we've seen
before that the meaning of a complement
changes based on what your Universal set
years okay so you have to be careful
that but this is uncertain
okay now where do we go from here there
are some numbers missing there's numbers
missing from here okay and they're
actually very famous numbers some of
most famous numbers in all of
mathematics in fact it kind of like the
superstars the ones that you learned it
they're special we don't even have you
know numerals for the weekend one two
three and so on these guys are so
special we don't even use our alphabet
we are out of that outfit for these
usually think about it think back to
like you seven one of us important
numbers your weren't about and it was
special and it didn't have a number to
play
pi is a Greek letter right what is it
it's well it's it's it's 3.14159265
three Baba okay and get to this in a
second now here's the important thing
right pi we often use 22 over 7 as an
abbreviation for it right it's close I
think it's yeah it's 3.14 two might be
3.14 is it wrong yeah it's something
else so it's within a third of a percent
of pi that's not bad you know that's
quite accurate like if you think of a
third of a percent of anything that's
not very much error okay so this life is
such a simple fraction not bad it's been
about 5% because if 3 is like you know a
hundred percent equals 3 anyway the
point is done pi is paid but one of
these is definitely okay so we need to
expand out and this is where our R comes
in I alluded to this before these guys
are the real numbers the real not ok
real so
these guys are really important what we
talked about real numbers okay I
honestly didn't internet when we talk
about Universal sets like what are
usually the numbers we're interested in
okay this by far is the most common
Universal set in all of mathematics
really it kind of is the giant he's the
main one you can go outside him as we'll
see in a second but we almost never do
okay real numbers how do you define
these these are easy to define these are
easy to define in terms of the previous
branches right so for example how would
you define rational numbers in terms of
integers is to a rational number yes it
is it's 2 over 1 yes how good okay so
it's what happens when you in not even
talking about fractions because this is
it's not really a fraction is it a
rational number is what happens when you
divide two integers that's it that's the
simple definition I can come up with
okay if you divide any of these you'll
get one of these what keep in mind you
gotta have some really reader kinds of
numbers in here right it's a big family
okay but what does that mean that
doesn't tell me what this is yes it's
these and these and it yeah that's
tricky
that's tricky cuz it's like what if you
miss one I'll talk about that let us
here's what I'm gonna give you I think
this is the best definition the real
numbers are all the numbers that if you
square them right if you square them
then the result will be greater than or
equal to zero
like so if X if X was a real number
right then x squared would be greater
than or equal to zero
those the real numbers every real number
even the widow's like pi you square em
they'll be zero or they'll be bigger
than zero can you see that that's true
of every number that I've written here
does that make sense integer sorry
natural numbers you square their
problems negative two square from zero
you square it you still get zero no
problems okay
fractions sorry fractions here you can
square I'm no big deal weird numbers
like this and I'll get to those guys
they're a whole branch and that's all
there is you can spray they're all good
yes okay so this is using our set
notation this means X is an element of
or belongs to or is a part of the real
number set X is iam are X's in the real
numbers or if you like you can just say
if X is real
you should do the double length it's
really easy by the way you just do one
line right and then you do another line
and then you do the are around him
that's all so so we use that for you to
make it Universal we use it for em zip Q
R to make it refer to these particular
one last step for you it's a scene I
don't know it stands for we've talked
about this we spent a whole lesson on a
moment it really actually stands dance
for what it's safer not within County
Seifer complex now not to be confused
with imaginary numbers
what complex numbers includes is well
look at how we define real numbers look
how we defined real numbers real numbers
are the numbers where you square them
and you get something that's greater
than or equal to zero
complex that most includes all the
numbers in all of these but it's got
some extra bonuses it's got numbers that
when you square them you don't end up
here huh right you can square there you
can get negatives you'll get other weird
stuff on different axes two-dimensional
numbers and so on okay so if you were to
draw a Venn diagram for these right
basically every time you go up you're
expanding at a level you'll have kind of
concentric circles here in the natural
numbers right
including the natural numbers but some
extra ones be integers right including
the equity integers but some other ones
the rational numbers
right including the rational numbers but
some other ones the real numbers and the
complex numbers come outside here okay
and that's pretty much all the sets that
we really need to worry